The sharks are back,
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
And your sales?
$30 and $40 million.
Whoa!
If the sharks
hear a great idea,
they are ready to invest,
using their own money.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
That is the slimiest,
the nastiest business--
welcome to
the real world, mark.
No--
Calm down!
What is this, "kumbaya"?
but first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark to invest
the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
Every time you get up here,
you take that opportunity away
from somebody
who really needs it.
It's sink...
I don't think we've ever
seen this in the tank before.
Or swim.
Anna Trebunskaya
and Jonathan Roberts
of "dancing with the stars."
Wow.
I don't like it.
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went
from working
as a waitress in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real estate empire.
Daymond John is a fashion
and branding expert
Who grew his homegrown
clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
(birds chirping)
(cattle lowing)
My name is Dan Holtz.
And I'm Liz Holtz,
and we live
in Warren, Vermont.
And we're the founders
of Liz Lovely Cookies.
♪♪♪
(Dan) Liz Lovely Cookies
are all-natural, gourmet,
vegan, gluten-free cookies.
They're the best
you're ever gonna taste.
Dan and I are
high school sweethearts.
We've been together
almost 20 years.
You wouldn't believe
the hardships
we've overcome
to stay in business.
Okay, a little to the right.
We survived the recession,
and we survived
tropical storm Irene
when our retail store
was destroyed
three days before
We were gonna open.
It destroyed
all of our product--
The whole store--
But we're unstoppable,
and we just kept going.
(Liz) Hi, Micki!
(fussing)
Last year, Dan and I adopted
our baby daughter Mccartney,
so now more than ever we need
help to grow our business.
If we got an investment
from the sharks,
it would mean that all of our
hard work will have paid off,
and we'll have the resources
to make Liz Lovely Cookies
into a household name.
(imitates explosion)
(laughs)
♪♪♪
Hi, sharks.
I'm Liz Holtz.
And I'm Dan Holtz,
and we're the founders
of Liz Lovely Cookies,
and we're seeking
a $200,000 investment
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company.
(Liz) a couple years after
the dot-com crash,
we were out of work,
in debt,
with unemployment
running out fast.
Meanwhile, I filled the freezer
with cookies
for friends and family.
The outcry was unanimous!
Everybody wanted more!
(laughter)
So, we started over
in the green mountains
of Vermont,
baking decadent cookies
using artisan techniques
and only the best ingredients.
Liz is the amazing baker,
and I'm the creative
sales and marketing guy.
And together,
we're an unstoppable force
that's overcome
every obstacle imaginable
to build a brand around
Liz's trade secret recipes
that omit
traditional ingredients
like wheat flour,
milk, butter, and eggs.
That's right. My cookies
are gluten-free and vegan.
Dan and I know
these are cookies
you sharks can really
sink your teeth into.
So, who wants a bite?
Absolutely.
I have one quick question.
gluten-free, dairy-free,
egg-free.
What are they made out of--
Sand?
(sharks laugh)
The products are made out of
a blend of rice flour
and some starches,
but don't let that fool you.
Liz, what are
the three different
flavors we're looking at?
(Liz) okay.
The one with the chocolate
is cowboy.
Then you've got
gluten-free chocolate fudge
and gluten-free
Ginger molasses.
(mark) It's really good.
Oh, I like the cowboy.
Is there nuts in it?
(Liz) Walnuts.
You see, that's the difference
between the cowgirl cookie
and the cowboy cookie,
is that the cowboy has nuts.
(laughter)
That is delicious. Wow.
Thank you.
And your sales?
Last year, we did just under
$1 million in cookies.
Wow.
(Daymond) ooh!
I wouldn't eat these
unless I had to.
They don't taste that good.
(laughs)
(Kevin) Why would
anybody eat this
unless they had to?
(laughter)
Well,
you're in the minority
thinking that
they don't taste good,
'cause lots of our customers
are not gluten-free.
Let me tell you this.
So, one in three
U.S. Households
is now catering to someone
in their house
who has to eat gluten-free
for one reason or another.
So this is
the best of the cookies
you wouldn't eat
unless you had to?
The very best.
(Robert chuckles) No.
You don't know this,
but I'm a gluten-free mogul.
No, I do know that, mark.
Oh, you do know? Okay.
So what got me interested
is because of
athletic performance.
Steve Nash and other athletes
now eat gluten-free,
so it's become
more mainstream.
But it's a very competitive
market,
as Kevin alluded to.
How much money do you make
on $1 million in sales today?
It's about 10%.
But we're nowhere
near scale
in terms of what
our profitability could be
in terms of cost and maximizing
our value on overhead.
How do you blow this up
so that you become
the brand for... sand
or whatever it is?
Okay, so that is
the opportunity
we have right now.
What's amazing about
our cookies is that
they're not the boxed,
sit on the shelf
next to 16 other brands.
This is a perishable cookie
that sits
in the bakery department.
How long is its shelf life
in that bag?
30 days
outside of the freezer.
What does it cost you to make?
About a dollar to make
one pack of two cookies.
So, two cookies are costing
what at retail?
$3.99 to $4.99.
(Daymond) That's a lot.
That's an expensive cookie.
You know, this is where
the price
of this category lives.
If you go and you get
a single gourmet
allergen-friendly cookie,
it's gonna cost you 2 bucks.
Do you have
a retail location in Vermont?
No. Actually,
the one retail location
that we tried
to put together
was destroyed three days
before opening
by hurricane Irene
in a flood.
We lost $15,000
and a whole summer's worth
of long nights
building things.
Did you think you were going
to survive through that
when that happened?
I mean, we are the most
relentless businesspeople
you're ever gonna meet.
That was the smallest setback
that we've survived.
Yeah.
Yeah, we've had--
We've had a lot of knocks.
When the recession hit,
it really hit our business.
We couldn't pay our loans.
We called the bank and said,
"we don't think
we can pay next month."
So what did the bank say?
"When are you gonna pay us?
We're gonna auction
all your stuff off."
And Dan and I decided
the only way
we're out of business
is if someone comes
and literally takes the seat
from under our butt.
You know, we were
out of money,
we were out of time,
but we just fought
and fought and fought.
We got really creative.
We built an e-commerce site,
and we just
sold, sold, sold,
and since then
we've worked our way up
to just under $1 million
last year.
How are you distributed,
and what percentage
of your sales are wholesale?
So, 90% of the sales
are wholesale, at least.
We are distributed
by the--the country's
largest natural foods
distributor.
We were just at the I.D.D.B.A.
trade show in New Orleans.
Essentially, every single person
that walked up to the booth
said, "We're looking for this.
This is great.
This is the best gluten-free
thing we've tasted yet."
Wow, you know, you're a good--
You're a good salesman.
(Daymond) You are
a good salesman.
Maybe they all just wanted
a free cookie.
(laughs) Yeah.
Did you get any actual
hard orders?
You--You don't get P.O.s
in the food industry
until you're ready
to deliver.
It's just not how it works.
You're a great salesperson,
so I-I think you guys work
amazing together.
Um, I-I have to be honest.
I really didn't like
the cookie.
I'm not saying it was bad,
but I wasn't in love with it.
And I have to be passionate
about something I invest in.
So I'm out.
♪♪♪
I see this as almost, like,
another, uh, loan
to bridge the gap
between what you need
and what you have.
And, uh, it's never
a good position
for an investor to lend money
in that situation.
So I'm out.
Well, let me speak to that,
because generally what happens
with food businesses
like this
is they expand
to about $3 million,
and they get to a place
where they're very interesting
to large players
in the industry
that want to add on
a brand.
That's the goal. We need to
get over that $10 million mark
to make this
a saleable company.
It's a big stretch.
Dan, I'm not as convinced
about the growth strategy.
I think that there's gonna be
a lot of competition.
I think you have
a journey ahead of you,
and I just don't want to go
down that journey.
Um... today, I'm out.
Um...
you're a very good salesman.
I have the ultimate respect
for the sales guy,
'cause that's what I am,
I'm a salesman,
and it's really hard.
You're good.
I just hate your product.
I'm out.
Well, Mark...
(Liz) It's down to you, Mark.
It's just you and us.
And I know that you're
into the gluten space.
And I-I have about
$1 million worth of business
that I'm percolating
just from one trade show.
I've got three
major grocers on the hook.
I've got a handful
of little guys,
and I've got a lot more
selling to do.
I know you hate
P.R. companies.
I know that you
can't stand schwag.
We don't do
any of that crap.
You know, I've always said
sales is the best market.
The way I market
this product
is I get cookies
into people's mouths,
I get cookies into the store,
and they look fabulous.
We also have,
and I love this--
Dan.
Yes, sir?
Let him go.
You know, I feel like--
I feel like you guys
aren't getting it.
And I'm not sure
what it is I'm doing wrong,
but this is a huge opportunity.
We're--the time's--
Man, you can sell.
I like everything
you've said.
One issue.
Valuation.
Okay, well,
let's talk about that.
What do you think
it's worth?
You know, I'm gonna let you
make me an offer.
I use this all the time.
I'll do the 24-second clock
spiel and all that,
and I'll say, "Here's my offer.
Take it or leave it."
Right? You got 24 seconds.
Mm-hmm.
We're gonna flip it.
Okay.
Make me an offer,
and I'll say yes or no,
and it'll take me
less than 24 seconds.
♪♪♪
Four sharks are out.
Mark Cuban is interested,
but he doesn't like
Liz and Dan's initial offer
of 10% of the company
for $200,000
and has given them
one last chance
to make him a final offer.
Could we step
into the hallway
and just talk about it
for a moment?
Yes, you can.
Okay, thank you.
Wow. He's a cool guy.
(Barbara) Yeah, he is.
I like him.
He is a great salesman.
But the valuation's crazy.
It is crazy.
(clears throat)
No way.
Hmm-Mnh.
So, Liz and Dan.
(chuckles) Yes.
You're gonna only get
one shot at this.
This is what I call
a yolo moment--
You only live once.
(chuckling)
What are you gonna do?
I don't we've ever seen this
in the tank before.
You're the first.
You either win big,
or you really screw it up.
Let's go.
Mark, we're gonna go
a little higher
than we were comfortable
going,
because we'd really like
to have you as a partner,
and we're gonna say--
Ask you if, uh,
you would do $200,000
for a 20% stake.
♪♪♪
No, thank you.
I'm out.
Thanks, sharks.
Thank you, sharks.
(Barbara) Thank you.
Whoa.
Ooh.
Oh, man.
What was your number?
I needed to get 33%.
33%?
Yeah.
What a moment.
(voice breaking)
We're gonna be fine.
You know,
we'll find another way.
But it actually--
It just bummed me out
they didn't like the cookies,
and it bummed me out
that they didn't believe
in us as people.
You know, I've heard them
invest in people before,
and, I mean, they were
impressed by Dan,
but I just didn't feel
like they got us.
Last season, we saw
Stephan Aarstol make a deal
with Mark Cuban for his
tower paddle board business.
So I'm willing to give you
$150,000
for 30% of the company.
Let's do it.
Whoo!
Let's see what he's up to now.
♪♪♪
Morning, girls.
Since making my deal
with Mark Cuban,
the growth has been
off the charts.
We went from just $100,000
in lifetime sales
to over $800,000
in just a few months.
I like it, dude.
They're looking good.
We're on pace to do
$1.5 million in sales
through our web site alone
this year.
Hey, mark. It's Stephan.
Mark Cuban
is amazingly accessible.
I don't think the guy sleeps.
He's behind this company 100%.
Ready, set, go!
(cheering)
(Stephan)
the "Shark Tank" experience
has really jumped my career
ahead probably 20 years.
It's a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity,
and this is just the beginning.
♪♪♪
Next up is Lee Dahlberg,
who is ready for a comeback
with his trendy
fashion accessory.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Lee Dahlberg,
and I'm the owner,
designer, and creator
of a company called
Rock Bands.
Today I'm seeking
a $100,000 investment
for 20% equity in my company.
Sharks,
I've developed a brand
that not only has people
looking good,
it has them feeling good
as well.
It's called Rock Bands,
and as simple as it sounds,
it is indeed
a rock on a band
that makes a Rock Band.
(laughs)
A little deeper
than that... (chuckles)
I use stones
that have healing elements.
Now, each Rock Band comes
in a backstage equipment case
from a rock concert,
keeping with its theme,
inside revealing the meaning
of your individual stone.
Now, each Rock Band
is hand-Carved
by a family of artisans
that's been carving
since the Ming dynasty.
(lid closes)
I created the first few
Rock Bands for me,
and I had some friends
that really wanted them,
and then their friends
really wanted them,
and I thought, maybe I've
got something here.
So I jumped in.
I sold my house
to begin the company.
I created
a guerilla marketing campaign
and I hustled,
and after a lot of hard work,
I was able to get in
four of the top retailers
in America.
Now, the only thing
I wasn't prepared for
were the politics
of retail.
So I definitely took
a few hits along the way.
But every fight led me
to here today in front of you.
Everyone that sees Rock Band
loves Rock Band.
That even goes
for the rich and famous.
You don't even have
to take my word.
You can take it from the voice
of the rich and famous.
That's right, sharks.
(laughter)
Rock Bands by Lee Dahlberg are
the hottest thing in Hollywood.
Oh!
Rock Bands can be seen
on the celebrity wrists
of Bono, Johnny Depp,
Brad Pitt, Angelina Jolie,
Tommy Lee, Britney Spears,
Lindsay Lohan,
even President
William B. Clinton,
and... me, Robin Leach.
Rock Bands--
The ultimate expression
of Champagne wishes
and caviar dreams,
individuality, and fashion.
Love that, Robin.
(Barbara) Wow!
We loved it.
Good job, Robin.
Very impressive.
Good luck.
Lee, how did you get him?
Um, we've been friends
for years.
Sharks,
I've taken the liberty
to create a Rock Band
for each of you...
Oh, cool!
Based--
Based on your
individual personalities.
Awesome. Thank you, Lee.
This is for you.
You brought out Robin Leach.
You got our attention.
Ah, exactly.
What do you have
for Mr. Wonderful?
Oh. You are a special one.
I hope it explodes.
(laughter)
Yeah. Yes. Here you are.
Ooh, I like that.
(chuckles)
So--So, Lee, you said
they had healing powers.
Yes, sir?
Do you have any idea
the history of people
who've come into the tank
talking about healing powers?
No--
No, I'm not the great wazoo.
You're not selling these
as medicinal
in any way, are you?
No--at the end of the day,
if it's a placebo,
it makes everyone smile.
Tell--Tell us about
your sales.
Sales. I've done about
$300,000 in sales.
Over what period?
Five and a half years.
(Mark and Daymond) OHH!
No--Ohh! Here you go.
What are sales gonna be
this year, Lee?
It all depends.
The one thing about the brand
is that I own
the trademarks.
Something came up
just recently--
a very well-Known
italian company
is launching in America.
They called me,
and we signed a contract.
They're gonna launch
under the name Rock Band.
So you licensed Rock Band
to them?
Yes.
It's called Rock Band by...
(speaks italian).
And they did $1 million
last year,
and they're think--
That's in Europe,
and my share is 40%
of all U.S. sales.
I'm sorry. They're gonna
give you 40% of net,
correct?
All U.S. Sales.
Of profit?
Gross or net?
Some of the negotiation
is about helping
in cost of manufacturing.
Okay. Hold on, hold on.
If they sell $100,000
worth of product--
Gross sales--Will they
give you $40,000,
or, after everything
is paid, said, and done,
will you get 40%
of the total profit?
Meaning maybe $10,000.
Uh, as it stands,
of the profit. You're right.
And you mentioned something
about politics of retail?
I had a large P.O. agreement.
How large was
your purchase order?
Uh, 150,000.
After it was manufactured,
well, they did in fact cancel.
Isn't a purchase order
a contract, though?
That's what I said.
And I was told, kind of,
um, "Sue us."
Walk me through the economics
of all this and this.
$12, and it, uh...
$12 for--everything in This
is $12?
Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
Including the case?
Yes, sir.
And what do you sell it for?
Um, that wholesales at $50,
and then retails--
Suggested $99 to $150.
Great margin.
How many units have you sold
in the last month?
A dozen a week. And I know
that's not impressive. I--
actually, it's not so horrible
at 150 bucks a pop.
I give you $100,000 today--
What are you gonna do with that?
30% will probably go to,
like, Web site optimization.
30% has to go to a-a lawyer
to protect the trademarks
that are already being
infringed of mine.
So what you're saying is,
you've had to fight
the game company that did
"Rock Band" the game, right?
Well, obviously, they have
the rights to do electronics...
right.
'cause that's not my field,
but what I have is clothing.
Oh, so you want to sue them
for making--for the clothing?
Yeah--I wouldn't say "Sue."
I would just say,
"Hello. Remember me?"
yes, of course.
We don't want to say
anything harsh.
(Kevin)
I want to make you an offer.
How about I give you $100,000,
and I buy Rock Band from you?
All of it. The whole thing.
(chuckles)
And I pay you
for the rest of your life
a 7% royalty on everything
I commercialize with that brand.
And by the way, I have
a whole bunch of lawyers
to take care of all
the problems of people
that have messed around
with our brand.
I'm sure your letterhead would
scare them a lot more than mine.
(chuckles)
No, I-I help encourage them
to do the right thing.
No, of course.
At the end of the day,
I could make a lot of money
with this.
I'm not sure the rocks sell,
so I don't really care
about that.
But I care about the brand.
Of course.
I could license this brand
in a lot of places.
Lee, I think you're unlucky.
This went wrong,
that went wrong,
and luck tends not to change
around businesses.
(laughs)
Are you kidding me?
(Barbara) I hope I'm wrong.
That is--
(Robert) You know what?
That is such crap.
Come on. You make
your own luck in life.
Don't tell the guy
he's unlucky and he's doomed.
I don't think you're unlucky.
You just got a shark
to offer you $100,000 cash.
I'm gonna join Kevin
on half his offer.
(laughs) "I don't want
to work you.
No, no, no.
There's everything wrong,
but I'm gonna go in, because..."
I was about to call her a witch,
but I'm taking that back now.
Oh, no.
Because I'm going to partner
with Barbara on this.
You get two sharks.
You get a shark and a sharkette.
50/50.
What are you gonna do?
Listen to the whispers
real quick.
(laughs) Smart man.
(Daymond)
Here's what I'm thinking.
I'm interested
in the business.
Mark and I, uh, invested in some
girls named Litter last year...
I was very aware of that.
And they are doing incredible.
If... mark agrees,
I'll give you the first $50,000
if he gives another $50,000,
and we would want 40%.
I don't like it.
Of course you don't like it,
because it's far better than--
'cause it doesn't
make sense.
It makes total sense.
The opportunity here
is to leverage
the two together.
All right, so, Lee--
Listen, Lee, you've got
to make a decision.
You have a real offer here,
all right?
Sure. We just don't want
to be--
got a lot of noise--
You've got a team here
that's been licensing masters.
Barb's proved herself on
television a zillion times now.
(Kevin) she's gonna put this
on television.
Oh, this is a shoo-In for qvc.
(mark) Lee, let me--Let me
quantify this for you.
Your challenge is...
back offers.
Fulfillment and back offers.
We've already done this,
so you'll be able to step
right in and just go to work.
And I think that's why we'll be
able to do a great deal.
(Barbara) But, Lee, think about
one other thing.
You're an artist at heart.
If you were to just
unload this business
and collect your check,
you're free as a bird
to develop your next dream,
the dream after that.
You're gonna have Kevin
and a real estate agent
designing jewelry after that.
Why would you wanna stay with
both feet in the business?
It's all attractive
in its own ways.
I-I see the benefits
of both, honestly.
That alone is proof
that you ought to be
walking out of this business.
Anybody's who's married
to a business
never sees the benefit
of walking away.
He's just being objective
and just analyzing
what's in front of him.
No. His heart's not in it.
Wow. Really?
Lee, I'm gonna make
one last statement,
and then I-I may actually
recant the offer.
I think that we can
license as well,
if the opportunity
provides itself,
but we will also let you work on
your dream instead of saying,
"You've been doing this
for three to five years. Leave."
Can we make sure
that the licensing
is an actual part of it--
absolutely. We're gonna--
Everything.
It's your company still.
You own 60% of the company.
So I'm gonna let you
answer us yes or no right now.
And you'll be inspired...
(Kevin) Lee, you have
to make a decision.
To seek out these
licensing deals?
You have to decide.
Basically, as long as you're
in--in the same interest
of licensing--
Yes, we will license it.
Absolutely.
Absolutely?
Yes or no?
Yes.
Good job.
Done deal.
Huge opportunity missed.
Good job, Lee.
Looking forward to it.
Absolutely.
All right, thank you.
Appreciate it.
All right.
Just because
we didn't make a deal
doesn't mean
you can't root for me.
Come on.
Put your hand in there.
(laughing)
Thank you.
Good job, Lee.
Looking forward to it.
(Kevin) Huge mistake.
(Lee exhales)
He's unlucky? Well, his luck
just changed, Barbara.
(Daymond)
His luck just changed.
Daymond, I'm not happy.
(laughs)
♪♪♪
Next into the tank
is Tereson Dupuy,
who invented an eco-friendly
must-have for babies.
Hi. My name is Tereson Dupuy,
and I am founder and C.E.O.
Of Fuzzibunz Diapers.
I am here asking
for a $500,000 investment
for a 15% equity stake
in my company.
This trash represents
the 1 ton of garbage
that one baby generates
in disposable diapers
by the time
they're potty-trained.
Disposable diapers make up
the third largest consumer item
in landfills today.
One disposable diaper takes
up to 400 years to decompose.
But, sharks,
I do have a solution.
Fuzzibunz are a 100%
reusable diapering product
that is easy to use
and easy to wash at home.
They save parents over $2,500
on their diapering cost,
because you only need
12 Fuzzibunz
in comparison
to 8,000 disposables.
They also keep
babies drier,
uh, more comfortable,
rash-free,
which is why I created them
for my own Baby 12 years ago.
So Fuzzibunz
are a pocket-style diaper.
There's a pocket in the back
that you insert
a microfiber pad into.
The lining is polar fleece,
so even though
the pad inside is wet,
the lining is staying dry,
so the baby's more comfortable,
and less diaper rash.
The outside is waterproof,
so everything stays
where it belongs.
Now let's talk
about the washing,
because I know
everybody wants to know
what do you do
with the poop?
(laughter)
So it's easy.
If it's solid poop,
it just plops right on
into the toilet,
where it belongs,
by the way.
It's never solid.
(laughter)
I'm getting there.
If it's less than
the ploppable variety,
we have a handy-dandy
diaper sprayer
that attaches
to a toilet,
parents can just rinse off
whatever's left over,
they put it in this mess-free
hanging diaper pail,
and then when they're
ready to wash,
you unzip the diapers
into your washing machine,
including the bag,
and your hands stay clean.
Thank you.
Feeling these really
makes you believe in them.
The color of money
for you.
Thank you.
Kevin, how's it compare
to the one you're wearing?
(laughter)
So who's ready
to invest in Fuzzibunz?
Stop generating
tons of trash,
and start generating
tons of cash.
How long you been
doing it, Tereson?
12 years.
12--Wow.
Whoa.
12 years.
Wow.
What are
your sales last year?
Last year,
they were $3.9 million.
Whoa.
(Barbara) Wow.
But I've sold
$24 million worth
with no advertising,
word-of-mouth only.
Where are they sold?
Internet sites.
No retail?
No big-box retail,
but we have boutiques.
How much profit did you make
on $3.9 million?
$20,000.
Oh!
Why is it so low?
Because I had
manufacturing problems.
We went overseas,
into China,
thought it was gonna
be a good thing,
until they took
all of my product,
patterns, et cetera,
handed it over
to somebody else,
so now she's
competing with me.
I can't even tell
the two products apart.
Kevin, are you paying attention
to what she just said?
Hey. That's why
you have a patent, my friend.
I have a patent,
but it wasn't very strong.
When I first started out,
I had no money,
couldn't afford
a good patent attorney.
And your factory
just gave this to her?
Yes. She was in Hong Kong.
She was my distributor.
Wow. The story
gets even worse.
I mean, you're in--
You're in the poo-poo business,
and poo-poo happens.
Yes, it does.
Did you Sue?
We are suing.
Wow. You know, in my business,
people always tell me you can
sue anybody for anything,
but good luck collecting.
(Daymond) Correct.
Right.
What do you think'll happen
to your sales
if by magical force,
your patent's successful
and you shut her down?
What incremental sales
would you get
as a result of it?
70% more.
Whoa.
Wow.
And you think your sales
would go up 70%?
Oh, yes.
Not just from her,
from all of the people
that are squatting.
Well, tell us more.
Whoa, sorry.
Seriously?
Who else--Who else
is squatting?
(Daymond) Who else?
A lot of people.
If you combine 'em all
and roll 'em up,
how much do you think
annual sales are?
I would say, if I had
to give a good average,
probably selling
between $30 and $40 million.
Total?
Whoa!
Okay. Hold on here.
They're all
breaching your patent?
Yes.
Now This is where
poo-poo really happens.
Mm.
Because frankly,
this is
a very hard business.
You've gotta get retail,
you've gotta get distribution,
you have inventory issues,
manufacturing issues.
Or you work with
my army of lawyers,
who sues everybody
into the stone age
until they agree
to a license deal.
That is the slimiest,
the nastiest,
the worst element
of business.
Welcome to
the real world, mark.
No! Look, if you're not
part of the solution,
you're part of the problem.
I am the solution!
That is absolutely
part of the problem.
This is why we have patents!
This is why we have law
in this country.
No, no, no, no.
You know what you do?
You out-compete.
Why have you not been able
to just kick their butt
because you're
a better company,
you're a better solution,
and you're a better execution?
And that's the position
I've taken this entire time.
Here's what I see--
You hit a roadblock.
And how you respond
is exactly what guides
your future.
Mm-Hmm.
Unfortunately,
it sounds like
you talked
to too many lawyers,
talked to too many kevins,
and you were rudder-Less.
And someone
who's coming in
is probably gonna
have to come in
and do more pooper-Scooping,
and I don't wanna be
in the pooper scooper business,
so I'm out.
I'm looking at you
and thinking of myself
at different crossroads
along the way,
where people stole my stuff,
things got in the way.
And I just had to persist,
and I see that in you.
What I'm not sure I trust
in you is your judgment.
Okay. Well, Barbara,
if you invest in me,
I will do whatever
you tell me to do.
But I have
no interest at all
in being the entrepreneur
for your business.
I'm an investor...
Mm-hmm.
An advocate,
but I'm certainly not
gonna solve all your problems.
I will not quit.
And I see the vision
for this company.
I've had a lot of challenges,
from divorce to, uh,
to manufacturing issues,
to... you name it.
It's just not
in my D.N.A. To quit.
I'm sorry to say
I am out.
Okay. Thanks.
Daymond, I'm winking at you.
You know, when you first
started talking all that poo,
you attracted
a really big fly over here.
Yeah.
But peeling back the layers
on this onion,
it's starting to stink...
Mm-hmm.
And I'm out.
Okay.
You seem to be looking
for a lifeline.
Mm-hmm.
I like to invest
in businesses
that are in upswing.
I think once a-a stone
starts rolling down a hill,
it's very, very difficult
to stop.
I'm out.
Tell me if any
of the assumptions
I'm going to make now
are wrong.
You're an innovator.
You practically created
the cloth diaper business.
I did.
Yet at the same time,
everybody else
took a huge part of it,
70% of it away from you.
Mm-hmm.
Some of that's your fault.
It just is.
I started this industry,
I grew it,
I did all of the footwork--
Look, I admire
your tenacity,
but I don't wanna join you
on your...
on your ride.
I wish you
the best of luck,
but I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Good luck.
Thanks.
I didn't get a deal
from the sharks,
but I'm not upset with them.
They told me the truth,
and they didn't do it from
a good business perspective.
But you know what stopped me
from getting a deal?
All of the I.P. squatters
out there
that are making tons of money
off my idea.
So...
Just look out.
♪♪♪
Next in are Mike Lane
and Matt Franklin,
with a product they hope
will get America
standing straight.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Mike Lane.
And my name
is Matt Franklin.
Our company is PostureNow,
and today we are here
seeking a $100,000 investment
for a 15% equity stake
in our company.
We have two very special guests
to show our product--
Anna Trebunskaya
and Jonathan Roberts
of "Dancing with the Stars."
(Barbara) Ah.
(jazz playing)
(Robert and Barbara laugh)
Wow.
Don't get jealous, Mark.
♪♪♪
God, that's so beautiful, huh?
Yeah!
Wow!
(cheering)
Well done. Well done.
(Mike) Nailed it.
Mike, can she do
the rest of the pitch?
(laughter)
Yeah, please. I would love that,
believe me.
Now we asked
Jonathan and Anna
to join us today...
to show the importance
of posture in ballroom dancing.
And good posture's not only
critical for ballroom dancing,
it's critical
for everyday life.
Unfortunately, today,
we're hunched over our computers
and our mobile devices,
and poor posture has become
a worldwide epidemic.
PostureNow is a simple device
that can be worn inside
or outside of your clothes.
In fact,
Mike's wearing one right now.
As you can see,
it is two neoprene arm bands...
(laughter)
We're still laughing at it,
just so you know.
When your shoulders
slouch forward,
it provides a gentle reminder
to keep your shoulders back
and your back straight.
It looks like "used by
law enforcement everywhere."
(laughter)
Yeah. No kidding, right?
I-I initially came up
with the idea
because I was looking for a way
to get rid of my beer belly
without actually having
to stop drinking beer.
And I noticed that when
I stood up straight,
my belly would
magically disappear.
And one of the biggest
surprises we found
is how the dance community
has really embraced PostureNow.
Yeah, Well,
posture and timing
in dancing is everything,
as Mark here might attest, yes?
Couldn't attest to,
actually.
Yes. He has the experience.
Have you tried it?
Well, I'm actually wearing it
right now, as I'm dancing.
Really?
Oh, 'cause you really
needed it, right, Jonathan?
(laughter)
You know what?
You can always get better.
How long have you
been selling these?
Or Have you been
selling these?
We've--to date, we've sold
about $330,000 worth.
Whoa.
And how much
do you sell them for?
Uh, $39.95.
What does it--
What does it cost to make?
Costs about $5 a unit.
So what's
your wholesale price?
We--We do wholesale also.
Wholesale price is $19.95.
How are you
selling them right now?
Internet only.
Every month on Google,
there are over
1 million searches
for "posture"
And posture-related keywords.
Are--Are chiropractors
and doctors
gonna get behind this and say,
"This is good for your back"?
I can't say they're
gonna get behind it,
but they've been
buying the hell out of it.
And you're saying
this company
is worth now
about $700,000?
$650,000. Yeah.
Yeah.
That's what we value at.
Okay, $50,000
between friends, right?
Yeah. Yeah.
Um, it's a lot of money
you're asking for this company.
I mean, you are
stacking the deck,
because you have Anna
and Jonathan in here talking.
Yeah. Why not?
But the only problem
is if they weren't here--
But you know what, Daymond?
They are here.
How much money have you guys
invested to this point?
Initially, we put
about 5 grand on a credit card.
Oh, $5,000 now
is worth $700,000.
I like those numbers.
These guys are drug dealers!
Hey, it's a great business.
Only in the shark tank can you
create that kind of wealth.
(Barbara)
So you do have a patent?
We do.
A utility patent.
And you only spent $5,000?
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. Pending.
It's--It's pending.
Oh, patent pending.
Ohh! Pending!
But also, we've gotten
some really good support
from chiropractors.
And another market which
we're just starting to hear from
is H.R. departments
of--of--Of huge
fortune 500 companies
that are like,
"This is preventative."
So how many corporate orders
did you get?
We have no corporate orders,
just inquiries.
Oh, you've heard
from them.
Something we want
to target.
Okay. Well, these guys
like to talk about what's wrong.
Let's talk
about what's right.
Let's do. Thank you.
I'd love to do that.
Okay. Let's get into
some real details here.
Okay.
You've done $330,000
in sales.
You've said
your net margins are 40%.
So you're making $132,000,
basically.
So you guys--
You're splitting it
and you're putting it
in your pockets?
Yeah.
Pretty much, so far.
I mean--
What are your real jobs?
Are they anything
to do with posture?
I-I'm a--I'm a sales director
for an art handling company,
so we--You know...
and I own
a little videography company
where I do
corporate training films.
Why did you not reinvest
that $132,000 into the business
since you already
have other jobs?
Well, to be honest, this was
kind of more of a Hobby.
And so now we're starting
to realize
this could be
really, really big.
It's a hobby.
You're pulling out some cash.
But, you know,
if I put money in,
I wanna know you're gonna
do it full-time.
I want to be the first guy
to quit his job
on--On national television.
(laughter)
You have tantalized me
with the idea that
there is a market for this.
I think it's
sort of semi-Interesting.
I'd give you 100k.
I want 50%.
I also want--
Not gonna happen.
(Daymond) Whoa.
You haven't heard
my offer yet.
Whoa!
It gets better, my friend.
I--Well, I've heard enough.
I've heard enough.
It gets better.
Let's--okay.
I'll hear you out, Kevin.
Always listen, all right?
$100,000 just doesn't
fall out of the ceilings.
Understood.
All right.
I'll give you $100,000.
I want 50%.
I want a star attached,
that comes out of your hide.
All right?
Okay.
And I want a 10% royalty
on Every unit sold.
If you own half the business,
why would you want a royalty?
I have to get
some cash flow back.
How do I get my money back?
How does it come back?
No. I would not
do that.
Whoo!
Whoo! Let's give him
a round of applause.
I just wouldn't do it.
No way.
So--So far I'm the only guy
that offered you anything.
But it's just
too much equity.
And I think you know that.
Well, what do you think
is a fair amount of equity?
Uh, the offer I made--15%.
No, that's insane.
That's what
I think's fair.
This is not worth
$600,000 right now.
Why not?
Because you haven't
proven it yet...
we've proven it
two years!
As a business.
It's sold $300,000!
You haven't proven
anything.
Yeah.
You put $5,000 into it.
Patent pe--
We took $5,000
and turned that into $330--
$5,000, patent pending,
and it's worth $700,000 now?
That's--Absolutely.
Well, then
you don't need the money.
You shouldn't
be here then.
This stage is for people
who need money and need deals.
And every time
you get up here,
you take that opportunity
away from somebody
who really needs it,
who appreciates the offer
of $100,000.
You know what? I-I'm--I'm not
begging for anything.
I'm offering something.
Oh.
Ooh.
♪♪♪
Mike and Matt have rejected
an offer from Kevin.
And Mike has likely
blown his chances with Daymond
due his arrogance.
I'm--I'm not begging
for anything,
I'm offering something.
Oh.
Ooh.
And--and I'm offering it
to you guys.
Do you wanna do something
with it?
No. I'm out.
Feel better?
You feel better, D.J.?
I do.
Wow.
Okay, good.
'cause they just took--
They just took the opportunity
of somebody
who really needs this...
Calm down, Daymond.
No. No.
You--Then write him
a check, Barbara.
Ay, ay--
You gonna write him a check?
Daymond, I think
I was being passionate,
I think you were
being passionate.
I'd like you
to reconsider.
Just--Just reason it out here.
Here--Here's why
I cannot reconsider.
Okay.
Honestly.
I'm gonna tell you
the truth.
Okay.
I know the product.
I like it. I wore it before.
Okay.
You did?
Yeah.
I was fascinated with it.
I was staying in the back,
as I usually do.
And then I ran my mouth.
Yes.
(laughs) So please--
Gut I'm gonna tell you
the honest truth--
I would have had
the same exact offer
without the royalty.
I'm gonna stay out.
Okay. Fair enough.
I don't know what
he's seeing wrong in you.
I mean, I've never
met an entrepreneur
who wasn't
as spunky as this guy.
But you got up on the wrong side
of the bed today.
Well, I--
What is this, "kumbaya"?
it's a business!
No, no. I'm just--
I apologize for Daymond,
the way he treated you.
That--I-I--
who cares?
Talk business!
Barbara, you gonna give him
an offer or not?
Or just keep preaching?
There's a lot
I like about this.
What I don't like is I think
your price is way out of line.
39 bucks? I think
it should be under $20.
It could absolutely
be done.
But I have to say that I am not
as convinced as you are
that its application is as broad
as you're suggesting.
And you were a little weak
in your presentation
on who's gonna buy it.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Wow.
Thanks.
That stings. (laughs)
Yep.
What you're asking for
is just nuts.
Uh, I'll give you
$100,000 for 40%.
No royalty.
Okay.
That's my offer.
Mark, we haven't heard
from you yet.
Well--
Whoa! What am I,
chopped liver?
Exactly. I-I--
"Thanks for your offer,
But, mark,
what do you think?"
Matt, there's a reason
you don't talk!
(laughter)
Robert, thank you
for the offer,
and we'd like
to consider it.
Are there any other offers?
They are working the room.
You know what?
I'm gonna pull my offer.
Because it seems like you're
trying to work me...
(exhales)
So I'm gonna work you.
But you know what?
That's a good thing.
Let him go.
It's that simple.
Here's where I'm at--
Absolutely. In fact--
Absolutely. We actually--
Sometimes it pays
to listen.
Isn't this wonderful?
All roads come back to me.
No, actually,
the undertaker--
We already know
what's happening with you.
I understand
on the equity.
Because there's 2 of you,
50% partners,
and if you give up 40%,
it just doesn't feel right.
So 35% for Matt,
35% for, uh, Mike,
and 30% for Mark.
But because there's
an evolutionary life, um, scale
for the product,
I do want a royalty.
Ouch.
Of $5 per unit,
only until
I get my money back.
Then it ends,
with the expectation you--
Mike, you have to quit your job.
Okay.
You have to tell me now.
I'm not gonna
get into a bidding war.
How do you feel?
I feel great.
We're in!
And I quit my job!
Let's do this!
I quit my job!
I don't have to
go to work on tuesday!
(Barbara) Sorry!
(laughs)
Thanks, mark.
Appreciate it so much.
Appreciate it.
You are two smart guys.
(Anna) Bye!
(Jonathan) Take care.
(Barbara) Bye, Mike!
(Mike laughs)
I didn't think they were
gonna go for the royalty.
I didn't think so, either.
I like you on that one.
I like that.
So may I have
a little celebratory dance?
Yes. All right.
Yeah.
If you don't mind,
Jonathan?
Go for it.
(laughter)
You deserve it today.
And, Jonathan, I'm not
gonna ask you to dance.
That's all right.
(laughing) I really don't
know how to dance.
♪♪♪